foreign
big big reminder buck and Crowder is
being re-platformed Crowder is breaking
the mold Crowder is doing what we did
two years ago leaving you big con he's
leaving YouTube I'm going 100 Rumble
why because he has two strikes and he
doesn't want to end up like night wave I
don't know what he's doing I don't know
what he's doing but I do know this I I
guess we could start with this right
already talking about it we might as
well
uh for Stephen Crowder staffer's exit
show after interrogations and insane
ndas now if you listen to ROTC you
already knew this was going on because
you know we know a little guys were we
right
turns out were we right turns out again
I mean like I don't think we've been
more right no about a person and like we
hit this guy
it was a [__] bull this was one of
those like the Robin Hood where he
shoots an arrow in between the arrow you
know
with one of our arrows well uh here's
what it says Stephen Crowder said
Draconian non-disclosure agreements to
his staff with a 100
000 breach of contract uh Steve I only
make 60 Grand a year
shut up Dad
how could you imagine
breach of contract penalty after media
uh media reported on allegations of
workplace misconduct and the right-wing
commentators Rumble show five current
Informer staff members said
last month it was reported on
allegations of bullying inappropriate
drug use and lewd sexual workplace
misconduct at latter with Crowder the
popular online show they recently joined
Rumble okay thanks for that a YouTube
alternative hey Chris we got a little uh
English we got a little ink as they call
it two hours after uh
how come Rumble doesn't treat us like
remotely as nice as any of these people
and we're not getting these articles
written up about us no you know we're
not we're not rubbing our debt well we
are rubbing our dicks all over each
other's shoulders but nobody's
complaining to the Press about it thank
you for reminding me any more sugar-free
cheesecake ad oh yeah they're actually
good oh yeah I bet they are you know
what else is good regular cheesecake
yeah two hours after we have how do you
say mediaite mediaite
mediaite yeah I don't know hey mediaite
this is a [__] name for a company it's
no Gawker okay well by the name Gawker I
think you can get that cheap after
Gawker published The Following before
detailing an internal stuff
just keep calling it a different one his
response to BuzzFeed red
uh an internal staff meeting with
lateral Crowder held in response to the
initial story in which CEO Gerald Morgan
told staffers they could no longer
communicate with former employees ndas
were sent out
question
[Music]
um
that's that's illegal right well it's
not and here's why Texas is a right to
work state so in Texas they could fire
you they don't have to give you a reason
for firing you so what they did is they
go there's new updated contracts you
either could sign it or work here or we
we wish you luck at your future Endeavor
what I'm saying is even in a right to
work state there are workers protections
right you could say maybe maybe the
Articles written poorly I would imagine
that they're not stupid enough to do
that well okay I would imagine they said
you're not allowed to talk to former
employees all about yes correct that's
what I'm about to get okay all right
because the way they wrote it it's like
you're not allowed to talk to anyone who
ever worked here I don't care if it's
the guy brought the Poland Spring Water
you don't even [__] I don't even want
to see you I [__] them the agreements
which were reviewed by huffpo were
emailed to current ladder with Crowder
employees on July 26th and right in part
employee maintains its promise promises
and Covenants to not disclose
confidential information and defining
the immense uh in the amendment company
provide employee with confidential
information During the period in which
employees in play by the company what
confidential information how much it
costs you to get a [__] a [__] suit
for your next Trump [__] song parody
Crowders panty sizes yeah like what are
you what are you talking about what
confidential [__] well here's this is
what you're doing here so this is what
happens they're just gonna say
everything here is confidential so let's
talk about anything the agreement added
that if the breach of contract should
occur the employees would be liable to
the company for liquidated damages in
the amount of a hundred thousand dollars
now this because they're the credit
Defenders I I haven't I know what they
have to say this story just came out but
the Crowder Defenders are going to be
like yeah it's a company he has a re
they shouldn't be saying confidential
stuff now I'd understand that if you're
running a satellite company or some
company with proprietary information
yeah you're doing a podcast bro like
what yeah you didn't this is a national
secrets you didn't found gray matter
with Walter White you know what I mean
like you're not coming up you know what
I mean you're not running a [__] Tech
firm you're just an idiot who does it
just put who wears [__] dresses and
dances around like a and I think the the
NDA thing is hilarious on the NDA by the
way this NDA thing was 100 it not only
because of it in response to that
Crowder hottest Crowder likes potato
microwave video because that came out he
didn't like it this is not to protect
any company Secrets What secrets does
Crowder have besides possibly his
sexuality so do you think do you think
that like
like I know that the other there's other
like the post story there's [__] that's
got yeah that's gotten under skin but
that that [__] that potato video that
that bothers me well we know for a fact
it bothers what I'm saying is that that
was entwined in some of these new
policies like they were definitely
thinking about that video too because of
some of the [__] that was in it you know
they were like we're in the [__]
leaks remember when we first played that
video I was like this is so stupid guys
I mean it's funny but it's dumb and
we're like oh no no this is all real oh
I'm sorry it's it's not in a funny
format but it's all real but it's real
but it's all real
um so it says you're the agreement added
that it's a brief breach of contract
should occur the employee will be liable
to the company for liquidated damages
the amount of 100K I hereby acknowledge
that the said damages are reasonable and
do not constitute a penalty and I
further agree that I will not consent to
the reasonableness of the said
liquidated the staffers were told that
they had to sign the NDA by Friday July
27th Crowder held the meeting in which
he warned staff against speaking out
Stephen was livid
this brings me joy we know he was
Stephen was livid of source close to
rumble host uh to a mediaite he and uh
Gerald Morgan said that they knew
someone was talking to you
uh oh the author of this piece based on
the article you wrote they said whoever
text messaged former employees about us
not being able to hang out with them
would be given amnesty if we confess by
two this is high school [__] okay
fighter Defenders here hero you're
looking at your hero this isn't High
School [__] this is straight up
psycho like authoritarian like you have
until 2 p.m and I will give you amnesty
and everyone else will fall to the blade
read the next line Marsh can you after 2
p.m I want you to read it to see
yourself like no one confessed then they
would see it as malice no one confessed
so they started interrogating a few
people what the flying [__] bro you run
a podcast
you run a podcast they broke out the
[__] battery cables and [__]
it is new Banner Lord DLC [__] stop
yay
I hate the Atkins shakes during the
meeting Crowder downplayed a sexual
misconduct allegation and said another
source close to the soon-to-be divorced
father of two hours for the record does
it I love whenever they write that in an
article it's the most useful census ever
everyone always downplays their sexual
assault allegations I feel like that's
just information that's always redundant
like he downplayed what do you think he
did leaned into it if you're not okay
with the guys playing sack tap then it
is this isn't the place for you
the source that why is why is Crowder so
obsessed with still being able to touch
people's balls
uh the NDA was insane said the source
closest to Crowder most employees were
scared because of it some talk to
lawyers about it because they were
afraid but they thought they didn't sign
it he would whatever whatever a former
ladder required employee said the NDA
and bullying tactics are a clear sign of
a toxic workplace culture that will not
be cleaned up anytime soon that's pretty
much it real real quick going back to
the the right to work state thing
yeah you can fire your employees for any
reason what you can't do is tell them
that the reason is because you won't let
them put your balls on their shoulder
anymore yeah if if you're not okay with
like it's the stuff he's not Crowder is
fighting harder for his right to touch
dudes balls than anything else he's ever
done in his life I've never seen this
and by the way you know Texas might be a
right to work state but it still falls
under the jurisdiction of the Equal
Opportunity uh you know our opportunity
commission so and again like and he's
coming back with those five step Crowder
you're the problem bud you're the
problem and we know exactly what's
bugging you don't think you do you'll
never find you never ever say our name I
don't care because you know what we know
we got to you we know we got we you know
what and I I really do apologize for the
employees that had their [__] fear
fear Crowders bisexual trt rage you are
gonna make me feel bad now I I I do I
feel a little bit that some of these
people were getting [__] battery
terminals to the nips yeah seriously so
you know Crowder good luck on Rumble but
now people see who you are and you're
not getting the protection you're used
to and even half the people that used to
[__] defend you are not going that
way this guy's kind of a [__] piece
of [__] he's a megalomaniac he's a
[__] crazy person Joe Rogan runs his
podcast with like two other people no
think about it maybe three but he does
this guy has a team for what what are
you doing you need a team for all the
stuff
I have a green screen and funny outfits
okay I'll get hammy down here in a
minute and he'll [__] do five skits
better than you've ever done in your
life okay we're just lazy
you're lucky you're lucky with lazy
Crowder you're real lucky we're lazy
um
uh we uh you're lucky I'm so [__]
broken not even the Adderall gets me
going like it does with you